hey guys I'm a B shart will welcome to
Abby's kitchen and another special
edition of toilet top where I help you
solve your toilet troubles help you have
healthier happier poop so today's
question comes from a very frustrated
mama who's concerned about our babies
bathroom behavior so let's take a look
Dear Abby it's been two days now and my
7 month old has not pooped it's not like
he hasn't tried every so often I see him
getting really red and I can see that
he's really giving it a go but poor
thing can't get any relief please tell
me that there's specific boots that I
can give him and also what can I do to
prevent this from happening again I
can't wait to hear your recommendations
please help sincerely backed up mom oh
poor babe and for you I know how hard it
is to watch our baby suffer but the good
news is that there are things that we
can do about it so there's a number of
reasons why our baby might be
constipated one it might be because we
Stern solace that's very typical - it
might be because we introduced a new
food and our tiny digestive tract is
just adjusting 3 they may be dehydrated
and four it could be just changes in the
environment or schedule so the good news
is I have some really great simple
strategies to help get your baby some
relief let's take a look number one
tummy massage so if you haven't started
solids yet and your baby is just
drinking breast milk or formula a good
tummy massage is really your best friend
so I like to use the I love you method
basically what I do is I take my index
finger and my middle finger together and
I go I down the left side love an L so L
down and then you an upside down you and
that really will help stimulate the
bowels to get things moving and
hopefully give your baby some relief
number two get those babies moving so a
lack of exercise can definitely cause
constipation with babies just like it
can with us adults so try to encourage
them to crawl walk and kick as much as
they can
I know baby II loved the Jolly Jumper
for days when he was having a hard time
moving his bowels so that's a really
great option but if your baby super
fresh and new and
not quite moving independently yet even
just peddling their legs like a bicycle
can really help them along number three
up the fluids the water works alongside
high-fiber foods to get the bowels
moving so try to offer your baby a few
ounces of water which meals throughout
the day
number four focus on fiber so when it
comes to foods for constipation it is
all about the fiber so for veggies we
love spinach pureed into baked goods or
pancakes steamed broccoli steamed
artichokes peas add the pancakes or
pureed baked or mashed sweet potato for
fruits we love stewed a pureed prunes
master sliced avocado path blackberries
cooked or pureed pears half raspberries
slice Kiwi or quarter fix now for greens
you want to look for high-fiber whole
grains like bran base cereal oatmeal or
quinoa then you want to add some protein
sources for fiber
I love almond butter curator cooked
beans chickpeas lentils split peas and
some gram flax baked into goods or on
cereal now let's talk about some things
that should definitely be avoided if
your baby is suffering from constipation
low fiber foods like white rice white
bread and pasta can be constipating for
babies other people find that things
like bananas applesauce
and baby cereal also could cause
constipation now it's not recommended
that you cut these foods out of your
baby's diet forever while baby it's just
kind of getting things moving along just
cut back and then hopefully you can
reintroduce those things into the mix
alongside foods that have lots of fiber
number two sensitive foods it's very
possible to your baby has some kind of
food sensitivity that may be causing
some kind of digestive issues so one
idea is to keep track of all the foods
that you're giving your baby and make
note where you see an apparent day just
if if shoes arise then make sure to take
those notes to your doctor before
cutting any foods out and number three
fiber supplements or laxatives most of
these products are specifically designed
for adults not babies so you should
never ever use a fiber supplement or an
over-the-counter laxative without
medical supervision if you've made all
of these changes and your baby's still
not seeing any relief in the bathroom
definitely follow up your doctor with a
list of symptoms and
any kind of notes that you've taken you
definitely want to get to the bottom of
this Agora comes a bigger problem I hope
that these strategies helps you and you
leave back to changing smelly diapers in
no time
now moms and dads I would love to hear
from you what has helped you and your
baby is feeling constipated leave me a
comment below give me the thumbs up and
don't forget to subscribe to the channel
I'll see you next time on Abby's kitchen
bye
[Music]